hello and welcome to feed Bakula the
show that says the stupidest things did
I mention it features user comments this
week Dark Souls 2 the sequel to the
smash hit soul sucker has finally
launched giving players a whole new game
world to run around and die repeatedly
in kevin gave Dark Souls 2 9 out of 10
praising a fantastic sense of discovery
and some very welcomed tweaks to the
original formula praise the Sun good a
real game now if it was for ps4 that
would be great I feel like a 9 is
especially high from Kevin it's a good
thing there goes my life for the next
month man oh man got this pre-ordered
for the PC
I can't wait to die so much game should
be made I'm glad this game exists I
won't play it be /c I don't have the
patience or skill but I'm glad there are
a variety of quality games out there a
bunch of very positive comments there
well apart from screw backer who took
the time to have something of an
existentialist crisis in the comments so
many idiot gamers nowadays I'm always
astonished to our ignorant some posts
are considering this is the age of the
Internet there is no hope I have no idea
where your opinion falls over Dark Souls
2 screw backer but at least we know how
you feel about the other side
so while Dark Souls 2 is definitely
riding a bit of a height wave at the
moment there's no denying the series has
tremendous longevity there are still
people streaming and blogging their
experiences with the first Dark Souls
even though it came out in September
2011 with that in mind it's no surprise
people are excited about the new
instalment but then not all of those
people were entirely pleased a number of
commenters raised doubts about the
graphical quality of Dark Souls 2 when
compared to the reveal footage it looks
terrible oh man another graphic
downgrade
so console shaders and lightning is
lower than PC version this game is
overrated so a Demon Souls and Dark
Souls subpar graphics it looks like an
early ps3 game and the usual story
problems that all Japanese games have I
really wanted to like Dark Souls ones
and this but I really can't see what all
the fuss is about only played each one
for about five hours and then got bored
not because it was difficult I don't
suck at Dark Souls or anything I just
don't like it
you're looking at state-of-the-art
gameplay move forward get killed
rinse and repeat with state-of-the-art
graphics at first I wondered if I forgot
to put my glasses on I'm a veteran of
Demon Souls and Dark Souls and I have to
say that this game is disappointing so
far the new engine makes it feel like
you're not really rolling on the ground
there's no shadow or ambient lighting so
it feels like your character is just
sort of superimposed on the map the
graphics are mushy to the point where
you can't really see where the
boundaries are for collision detection
the NAI is pathetic some of the enemies
have obvious AI scripts but don't always
apply and it's hard to see the pathing
because the textures and resolution is
so poor come on
so where is the fun in this game it's
cool because it is challenging a game is
supposed to be fun not a job I guess is
the same view so it makes sense
Oh what kind of nonsensical hipster
argument is that oh I guess you'd like
it so that makes sense
you chode directions actually those
graphics look like [ __ ]
wow they really don't grade the graphics
big time the reveal footage is way
better especially the lighting at
Resident Evil 6 cutter for kicks rocks
how how can you still be complaining
about Resident Evil 6 how is this still
a thing how how how how how
oh yes apart from the people going wow
this isn't titanfall most people with
negative feelings toward Dark Souls 2
were focused on the graphics and you can
sort of see why the console version does
look a little bit flat maybe that's
something the PC version will manage to
escape time will tell on that front but
hey if the only bad thing people have to
say is that it doesn't look very nice
that's still not bad going I should know
people have been saying I don't look
good for years now but then they've also
called me pretentious and implied I have
deep-seated psychological issues and
that I'm bad at my job and that no one
will ever love me oh I made myself sad